remember this it's 1994 and Sky News is
visiting London's first internet cafe
the world wide web is growing fast
spreading new lines of communication and
giving anyone anywhere a chance to have
their say it allows anyone to publish
their information for a few pounds you
can put an article on to the network and
30 million people can read it that 30
million now an estimated 3.2 billion and
that freedom to publish and read and
build what you like has come with
consequences its creator Sir Tim
berners-lee says it's time for a rethink
it used not to worry me because I felt
the my duty as a web user was just to go
and find the stuff which I appreciated
which our justice but now I I think
everybody involved in the web realize is
that the problem is that other people to
go out there other people are reading
stuff which is complete garbage and
they're believing it and they vote the
problem well the biggest problem is the
massive centralization of Sims
originally decentralized web instead of
going from website to website
everybody's on one web site and so the
structure of people making great links
to other web blogs and so on which would
happen we had off the top 10 years of
the web there's more broken because you
people don't follow links from website
to website they says it's a 1-bit
website and what they see is determined
by the people who code that social
network so Tim is too polite to name the
network but there can't be more than a
few candidates between them the biggest
companies dominate the digital landscape
it's with those sites and governments in
mind that last week
sir tim launched his charter for the web
a Magna Carta of digital rights as an
individual you need to hold those
companies accountable and you need to
hold those government's accountable city
was also working on something even
bigger a new web and this time he's
going to get it right
the key change is to do with data the
Tim's new web called solid let you take
control of where your data goes and how
it's used a potentially seismic shift
one with popular anger on its side a big
backlash against the mistreatment of
personal data realization that
individuals should control their data
and people demanding and using system
and using turnitin great explained more
and more systems where they do control
their own data that's what I see as
being the next revolution starting right
now he led the first charge now Sir Tim
is back a quiet revolutionary with a
renewed sense of cause role amantha
Sky News